[Music]
so there's a whole bunch of different
inputs and outputs and actually let me
open this up um open up this in another
tab I'll just open up there because
um there are many examples for the
different inputs and outputs so here we
have inputs so what we saw before was
the slider input
and if you click on this over here
you'll see a really basic example of
that but there's also text input so I
can enter text here say hello shiny
and this example app will
show how to use that
there's an American put so it's similar
to the text input but
uses a
number input and you can there's little
arrows on it
check block input check box input which
you can just
turn on and off by checking it right or
Sorry by clicking on it
and there's a whole bunch of other ones
so there's groups of check boxes there's
um there's radio buttons
there's a select input that has a drop
down box
and dates and date ranges so these are
these are just uh these are the built-in
inputs for shiny
with all these inputs they all sort of
have a common format where you say UI
dot input something
and then the first thing that it's going
to have here the first argument that it
takes is an ID
and then a label for it and then there's
there's typically other parameters as
well
so in this case we're not using any of
the other parameters but uh
so if we go to the slider input
it'll have you have to set the minimum
and maximum value
for the slider as well as like as well
as the starting value
one thing that you can do with these is
if you have an idea of what of the kind
of components that you want to add to
your application is
uh
you know let's say we're working on this
application here and we want to add like
a checkbox to it so like if we want to
be able to negate the value so I can say
I'll put a comma there just because that
will help this Auto completion I can say
UI dot input underscore checkbox
and then friends and then I can give it
a name like um
a gate
the gate
slider value I'll call and use that as a
label
and I can click on this button and it
will
uh it will provide this checkbox which
right now doesn't do anything we need to
actually use it in our application
so
let's see so let's say how would we do
this here so we see if we say if
input dot negate
then
um
I'll call this
plier
is negative one
else
multiplier multiplier equals one
all right and then I can put this here
and if I rerun this
then
this will work here no I didn't actually
fix the texture with this n times two
but but you can see how this works that
just simply you know clicking on this
will cause
this code to re-execute and this this
value will be updated and
and again you know if there's other
types of inputs that we want to use we
can just refer to this examples page
here I'm in another browser Tab and I
can just look for different types of
inputs to use
foreign
[Music]